you can tell a lot about a society by
what
shocks its leaders for generations what
shocked the people in charge of this
country was political violence
hurting your neighbors for having
different opinions they were appalled by
that and they were right to be
political violence isn't simply an
assault on individual americans
it's an attack on america itself in this
country we govern by consent not by
force
people with guns don't make our laws
voters do
you may have a glock in your hand but on
election day you have precisely as many
votes as the little old lady who
disagrees with you
that's our system the weak are supposed
to have as much power over the
government
as the strong and that is the basis of
our equality
as americans something that we should
cherish and protect
political violence immediately
short-circuits this it ends democracy
violence instead returns us to the most
primitive of all systems
one in which might makes right people
who hurt
others get to do exactly what they want
everyone else has to obey them
there is no greater threat to
civilization than this and we used to
understand that because it's obvious
but things have changed the people who
run this country are no longer shocked
by political violence they welcome it
they slyly
encourage it they are its beneficiaries
they tell us the only real crimes are
thought crimes
it's okay to set fires or smash
strangers in the face with two by fours
so long as you are chanting the correct
slogans if you're on the right team
everything is allowed but if you dare to
dissent from the orthodoxy
you will be swiftly punished go ahead
and express the wrong opinion
try it in a meeting try it on facebook
they will find you
you'll lose your job your reputation
possibly even your life
the message they're sending you is very
clear americans are not
equal anymore there are two standards in
this country one standard for them
and a very different standard for you
over the weekend we saw exactly what
they will excuse from their own
supporters
armed mobs of joe biden voters torched
buildings
smashed cars attacked police officers
they rioted
they hurt people a lot of people and the
media
watching closely lied about all of it
they pretended it didn't happen they
made excuses for it they
buried the truth in euphemism the liars
the new york times described the riots
as quote
protests as if the violence was
justified or
could be justified here's the truth
about what
happened here's what actually happened
in seattle over the weekend
take a look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
protests no these were not protests
these were scenes from war
the rioters threw rocks bottles wood
explosives at police
one explosion left an eight-inch hole in
a police precinct
because no lie is too absurd for cnn to
tell
the network described violence against
police as
quote a demonstration against police
violence
got that it's a perfect inversion of the
truth
worthy of 1984 ignorance of strength
freedom of slavery
war is peace they repeat it because they
expect you to believe it and no doubt
some do
the seattle police department gamely
tried to push back by releasing
actual body cam footage of the violence
it's not clear how many people saw it so
we're going to show some of you
we're going to show some of it to you
right here
[Applause]
a total of 59 police officers were
injured in this
demonstration against police violence
cnn would like you to believe they
attacked
themselves they did not not in seattle
not anywhere
in oakland mob with mobs with helmets
and shields attacked a police station
they shot cops with fireworks they set
fire to a courthouse
hear pictures of it
[Applause]
according to abc news the rioters you
just saw were quote
protesters they burned the courthouse
quote
after a peaceful demonstration
intensified
oh intensified just like the world trade
center collapsed when a commercial
airline flight
intensified it's remarkable
you've got to believe there are still
normal people working at abc news maybe
in the tape library or in the cafeteria
are they watching their own coverage how
can they stand it
the apologies for violence the
relentless
shameless lying it's hard to believe
they haven't resigned
they probably have mortgages and kids
you feel for them just as you feel for
the cameramen who had to flee the mob in
sacramento over the weekend
they were surrounded and apparently
assaulted by 150 joe biden voters
dressed in black paramilitary gear
and had to run for their lives you'd
think other journalists would be
sympathetic to this they used to be
not anymore the stakes are too high
we've got an election coming up and so
instead they
lied to provide cover for the rioters
the ones who threatened
the cameramen the sacramento bee took
pains to tell you that the protests were
actually peaceful
the newspaper did its best to downplay
the violence including the fact that
so-called protesters were trying to
disarm police helicopters
with laser pointers one of the peaceful
protesters ran through the streets with
a chainsaw
in order to block traffic no problem
nothing to see here
meanwhile at mostly peaceful protests in
austin and aurora colorado people were
shot
in downtown louisville heavily armed
militia and military outfits walked
through the city
threatening violence if police officers
weren't sent to jail no problem just to
protest
in milwaukee a black trump supporter
named bernal trammell
was executed in front of his office in
broad daylight
he was killed in portland oregon police
seized a bag filled with rifle magazines
and molotov cocktails not a big deal
city leaders in portland have ignored 60
straight days
of rioting it's fine they say really
here's how portland looked over the
weekend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey
uh
this isn't fine it's not normal it's not
a protest
these aren't children these are adults
and they're destroying our country
they're completely out of control
they're violent are they punished no
where's the justice department in this
don't we have an attorney general
isn't he supposed to be conservative why
are we allowing this
chad wolf runs the department of
homeland security wolfe whatever you
think of him has been one of the very
few officials in washington
who seems to notice that any of this is
happening he sent federal law
enforcement to portland to keep the mob
from burning down the federal courthouse
there which the mob does not own
it's federal property they have no right
to torch it it's not theirs
it's ours for doing that for being one
of the very
few to actually push back a little bit
he was punished the mob came to
chadwolf's home yesterday
and they threatened him and his family
and they didn't do it subtly there
wasn't subtext they said it out loud
on camera watch we must
make social consequences for these men
and women
[Applause]
we must make it uncomfortable for them
we will not
be good germans we are angry
[Music]
this man lives here quietly and is able
to live
just like us oh
he's starting to figure out why the
department of justice isn't actually
doing anything why they haven't frog
marched the leaders of antifa in front
of the camera
why they haven't stopped this stuff
while they're acting like they're
powerless
maybe they don't want mobs like this in
front of their houses
maybe mob violence works we must make it
uncomfortable for them
she says in a megaphone what does that
mean well we don't need to guess
because we just spent all weekend
watching what it means
here's the contrast that we should never
forget things change so quickly you
imagine things have always been this way
but they haven't
there's a presidential election a few
months from now if you disagree with
with what chad wolf has done you get to
vote against chad wolfe's boss
and chad wolf would be out of a job
that's the way we used to do it
when this was a democracy but not
anymore now they just go and threaten
chad wolfe's children
and the media applaud last month a radio
show host in seattle called paul gallant
mocked reports that his city was
descending into chaos
these were peaceful protests he
suggested on twitter gallant reported
that he saw
no burning pillaging or deaths
of course those things were happening
they existed we show you tape of it at
the time
but gallant pretended otherwise we don't
know why we'd have to assume because he
thought it would help his team
then the rioters showed up in the
building where he lives in his apartment
building
and they destroyed destroyed the
starbucks downstairs and that scared him
now galon says he's buying a gun
ah it turns out it's not so easy to lie
about violence
when it's aimed at you